[Musique]
la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il en a-t-il en séance je
nenvoie point le procès verbal est
adopté sous les réserves
d'usage madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance retransmise en direct sur
Public Sénat et sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des et
des autres et au respect du temps de
parole et je donne immédiatement la
parole à notre collègue François bonau
pour le groupe de l'Union CCE vous avez
la
parole monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ns
pensé vol vers l'Orient ensanglanté par
les terrorist du Hamas nourr par la
haine la barbarie et les actes
génocidaires depuis 2007 la bande de
Gaza est sous la coupe de ce mouvement
islamiste qui veut détruire l'état
d'Israël ses habitants subissent depuis
le 7 octobre dernier à la fois un blocus
et des frappes qui font nombreuses
victimes civiles prisonnières des
casstiges du
mouvement comment recréer l'espoir d'un
monde meilleur chez toute une jeunesse
palestinienne rongé par la corruption
d'une partie de ses élites et dont
l'horizon se heurte au mur de
l'indifférence la solution à deux états
exprimée avec constance par la France
paraissait dépasser à l'époque para
dépasser à l'époque où la sjordanie est
devenu un immense gruyère du fait de la
colonisation massive à l'heure où le
président de la République veut à la
fois soutenir la population et la
démocratie israélienne traumatisé et
fragilisé par une crise institutionnelle
mais aussi desserrer les taux mortifères
sur Gaza des questions se
posent l'idée avancée en particulier
d'une large coalition contre le Hamas
interroge de quelle nature serait-elle
avec qui avec quel moyen la constitué ne
suppose--il pas d'intégrer le Hamas à la
résolution déjà votée par les Nations
unies contre l'État islamique l'ONU
voteritelle cette résolution et surtout
comment une telle coalition
pourrait-elle protéger l'État d'Israël
et de ses voisins hostille éviter
l'embrasement pour créer à terme les
conditions d'un retour à la paix
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur des Françis et de l'étranger
monsieur
Besch merci monsieur le Président
madamees messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur François bonau
d'abord je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères qui est sur le
chemin du retour du Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies à New York oui vous
avez raison et le président de la
République la
rappelé nous sommes en solidarité et en
émotion à l'égard de la terrible épreuve
que le peuple d'Israël a subi le 7
octobre dernier une attaque terroriste
sans précédent dans l'histoire d'Israël
le président a tenu à rencontrer les
familles françaises les familles des
victimes et des disparus 30 de nos
compatriotes ainsi que 9 français encore
manquant à l'appel la libération de tous
les otages parmi lesquels au moins une
française est une priorité monsieur le
sénateur Israël a évidemment le droit de
se défendre face à un groupe terroriste
qui a pour objet sa destruction dans le
combat contre le terrorisme les
démocraties doivent être unies et
solidaires et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela
que le Président de la République a
évoqué l'idée d'une coalition
internationale comme nous l'avons fait
dans le cadre de la lutte contre daesh
je rappelle que l'idée d'une coalition
internationale n'est pas simplement les
actions de terrain mais c'est aussi les
échanges d'information dans le cadre du
renseignement c'est la lutte contre le
financement du terrorisme c'est
également la lutte contre le djihadisme
en ligne ce sont des points qui peuvent
faire l'objet d'un travail dans le cadre
de cette coalition le président a
également rappelé que toutes les actions
qui doivent se mener doivent se faire
dans le respect du droit international
du droit de la guerre guerre et du droit
humanitaire la France est en soutien
également des populations palestiniennes
avec 20 millions d'euros d'aide et nous
soutenons vous l'avez rappelé je vous en
remercie la solution à deux États qui
est la seule qui permet durablement
d'imaginer deux peuples vivants côte à
côte en paix et en sécurité je vous
remercie monsieur bonau
oui monsieur le ministre sans réponse
claire à ces questions l'éco des pleurs
et des lamentations enta longtemps nos
conscience il est urgent
d'agir la parole est à notre collègue
Jacques fernck pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité
territoire merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre Clément Baune
resterez-vous sourd aux appels à arrêter
le projet d'autoroute a69 entre Toulouse
et castre
vous annoncez depuis des mois que
plusieurs projets routiers seront
arrêtés parce qu'à l'heure de la
planification écologique on ne peut pas
faire comme avant c'est vous qui le
dites et vous avez raison alors comment
pouvez-vous refuser de remettre en cause
la 69 ce projet autoroutier daté typique
d'un temps révolu où étai clairement
sous-estimés les enjeux écologiques
votre ministère délégué et rattaché à
celui de la transition écologique c'est
pour lui que le Conseil national de la
protection de la nature est chargé de
l'expertise sur la biodiversité il a
émis un avis défavorable sur ce projet
autoroutier l'autorité environnemental
compétente pour ce projet a rendu aussi
son avis elle a jugé ce projet
anachronique reposant sur des données
obsolètes et puis
1500 1500 scientifique au moins certains
parmi les plus respectés au plan
international sur le climat vous disent
que la 6 69 est un de ces projets
auquels il faut renoncer monsieur le
ministre qu'est-ce qu'il vous faut
encore la parole est au ministre délégué
en charge des transports monsieur
Clément
B merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jacques fern vous connaissez
bien ce dossier et nous avons échangé en
toute honnêteté avec vous à beaucoup de
reprises sur beaucoup de sujets je
connais votre honnêteté intellectuelle
peut-on rester sourd aux besoins des
habitants du Tarne peut-on rester sourd
aux élus très majoritaires de ce
département et de l'ensemble du tracé de
l'autoroute a69 qui l'attendent et le
réclament depuis de nombreuses années et
même des décennies peut-on rester sourd
monsieur ferern quand on est un
républicain comme vous l'êtes et j'ai
demandé au préfet du TER de les réunir
tous en préfecture il y a encore
quelques jours à cet avis à cette
impatience aux élus de différentes
sensibilités politique madame Delga du
Parti socialiste monsieur Ramon du Parti
socialiste le maire de castre qui est du
parti les républicains il y a
différentes sensibilités politiques et
j'ai même entendu des écologistes qui
font partie de la majorité régionale de
Madame Delga qu'on dit que ça n'était
pas un motif de rupture avec Carole
Delga signe qu'on peut au moins en
discuter même si leur opinion est connue
sur ce sujet peut-on rester sourd à tout
cela quand dans une démocratie la
décision publique vous importe comme
elle m'importe et je dois la faire
respecter quand il y a eu des 500
réunions publiques quand les élus dans
leur immense majorité je leur dis ont
confirmé et reconfirmé leur avis et
leurs attentes quand les procédures
juridiques que vous évoquez monsieur
fernic parce que tous les avis que vous
mentionnez ont été utilisés à l'appui de
recours plus d'une dizaine tous et
encore un référé il y a quelques jours
ont été écartés par le juge nous sommes
dans une démocratie et dans un état de
droit tout le monde a le droit d'avoir
une opinion vous avez la vôtre elle est
est respectable on peut même manifester
pour défendre son opinion il y a deux
choses qu'on ne peut pas faire céder à
la violence et j'aimerais que vous
condamniez aussi les débordements les
violences graves qui ont eu lieu face à
nos forces de l'ordre face aux agents de
l'État face au services publics samedi
dernier dans le Tarne et il y a une
deuxième chose il y a une deuxième chose
quand on est républicain et quand on est
démocrate vous l'êtes qu'on ne peut pas
accepter c'est quelle que soit son
opinion ce n'est pas une minorité une
minorité qui dicte sa loi à la majorité
qui a affirmé sa et la
répéter
merci monsieur F monsieur le ministre
que ce soit bien clair mon groupe
déplore mon groupe réprouve mon groupe
condamne ces actes de violence ils ne
sont pas tolérables alors non je vous en
prie ne les laissons pas nous empêcher
d'être à la hauteur du débat de fond oui
bien sûr il y a la légitimité d'élus qui
ont porté ce vieux projet depuis
longtemps bien sûr il y a l'état de
droit il il y a aussi l'état d'urgence
climatique l'urgence pour la
biodiversité et la légitimité des
générations
futures pouvoir admettre qu'on a pu se
fourvoyer se tromper c'est ce qui fait
l'excellence de la démocratie il n'est
pas trop tard pour en être à la
hauteur la parole est à notre collègue
Laurent saumon pour le groupe les
républiqu est partout
madame la ministre les maires et élus
locaux expriment de plus en plus un
sentiment de lassitude voire de
désespoir avec corollaire le nombre
important de démission ils invoquent que
tout devient trop compliqué trop
difficile amputé des moyens que
nécessiteraient leurs compéten qui
elles-mêmes se réduisent tout ce qui
hier était simple devient inaccessible
la liste des difficultés qu'il rencontre
est longue mais une nouvelle surgie avec
prignance celle de contracter une
assurance susceptible de les protéger
face à la hausse de la sinistralité les
primes d'assurance les cotisations lambe
en meurt et Mosel Laxou 15000 habitants
ayant souffert des émeutes de juin
reçoit sans contact préalable un
courrier de résiliation pure et simple
pour le 1er janvier 2024 dans le Nord à
mondaluin un maire dont la commune est
reconnue en état de catastrophe
naturelle peine encore des années plus
tard à obtenir réparation le maire
d'Arcueil qui bien que ne faisant pas
partie des villes franciliennes les plus
touchées par les émeutes reçoit un
avenant faisant passer de 1500 à 2
millions d'euros la franchise a acquitté
par la collectivité en cas de dommage
alors que les risques se multi émeut
sacage inondation rétractation
gonflement des argiles et autres risques
climatiques les communes en somme en
France se retrouvent démunis pour
protéger leurs biens dans la recherche
même d'une assurance susceptible de les
protéger les compagnies peu nombreuses
dont le nombre ne cesse de se réduire
leur fond fau bond non réponse aux
appels d'offre des tarifs prohibitifs
certaines communes se retrouvent sans
assurance ce qui les laisse seul face au
risqu sans assurance elles ne peuvent
bénéficier du régime de catastrophe
naturelle on imagine les conséquences
financières en cas de sinistre grave
face à cette situation quelle mesure
madame la ministre comptez-vous faire
pour permettre à l'avenir que toutes les
collectivités puissent
[Musique]
s'assurer pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités territoriales madame
Dominique fort merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur saumon
oui vous avez absolument raison beaucoup
de collectivités rencontrent et de plus
en plus des difficultés à s'assurer
pour toute ou partie de leurs biens et
de leurs activités oui c'est un problème
pour toutes celles qui n'ont pas les
moyens de s'auto-assurer payer les
dégâts en cas de sinistre d'autre part
les assureurs sont des entreprises avec
leur modèle économique et avec leurs
contraintes quand on a un appel d'offre
infructueux ou qu'on assureur résilie un
contrat il le fait sur la base d'une
analyse
économique qu'on ne peut pas lui
reprocher de faire et c'est en général
lié au fait que le taux de sinistralité
de la collectivité est élevé et c'est
dégradé quelques mots pour vous dire
parce que j'ai reçu la smacle récemment
c'est 46 millions de dégâts pour la
smacle qui est le gros assureur de
collectivité cette année suite aux
émeuts alors que c'est de l'ordre de 4
million d'euros par an 46 millions cette
année heureusement la Maïf est rentré au
capitale de laasac et heureusement ils
ont abondé à hauteur de 100 millions
mais c'est pour vous dire que le sujet
est complexe la première étape parce que
le sujet est urgent c'est de créer le
dialogue nous avons obtenu en septembre
la mise en place d'une médiation de
l'assurance elle est déjà à l'œuvre sur
certains dossiers liés aux émeutes elle
nous a permis dans certains cas comme
celui de la commune de mont-sain-martin
où je suis allé la semaine dernière
d'obtenir le report de certaines
résiliations et d'esquisser des
solutions ensuite il nous faudra mettre
des solutions sur la table comme vous
l'appelez de vos vœux il a le sujet de
l'équilibre du marché comment les
assureurs peuvent-ils trouver leur
équilibre sur un marché sur lequel la
sinistralité comme vous l'avez dit
explose ces dernières années à cause de
catastrophes naturelles et puis il y a
plein de petits sujet opérationnel dont
je me suis saisie qu'il faut regarder
comme travailler et développer la
prévention bâtimentaire pour faire
baisser cette sinistralité pour faire ce
travail avec Bruno Le Maire nous avons
demandé un rapport au
ah aux inspections générales il y a deux
personnalités qualifiées Alain chrétien
maire de
vezou que je salue et puis Jean dages
ancien président de la Fédération
nationale de groupe H nous aurons le
résultat de ce travail que je viendrai
vous présenter en priorité d'ici février
prochain merci à
vous monsieur
saumon dem de
Rapp c'est une situation difficilement
acceptable par les ma je l'ai dit qui
contribu à leur découragement dans
l'exercice de leur fonction mais déjà en
2019 notre collègue sylvien Noël
interrogéit le gouvernement sur cet état
de fête rien n'a évolué les maires
notamment les maires des plus petites
communes attendent un réel soutien de
l'État où n'auront-ils d'autres choix
que d'abandonner j'aurais pu citer
d'autres communes ayant subi les mêmes
constats de désassurance comme
saint-billeux Saint-Omer ne leur
restera-t-il qu'à se vouer au sein pour
les
protéger la parole est à notre collègue
Saïd Omar wali pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la
parole vous savez monsieur le ministre
que la population maoraaise souffre
depuis plusieurs mois de cette crise
majeure de l'eau dans un territoire où
plus de 100000 habitants selon l'c déjà
n'ont pas l'eau courante j'ai pu mesurer
concrètement la semaine dernière sur le
terrain les premières mesures que votre
gouvernement a mis en place et qui va
falloir amplifier en
2024 car la crise est loin de se
terminer je veux aussi le dire
solenellement qu'en période de crise
majeure tous les acteurs doivent tirer
dans le même sens je puis constater la
forte mobilisation des maires des CCAS
mais aussi des fonctionnaires de l'État
dans les militaires de la sécurité
civile en période de crise on doit se
serrer les coudes loin de cerelle de
chapelle et des égau de chacun pour
illustrer mon propos les élus de Mayotte
en sortant de la rencontre avec le
président de la République vendredi
dernier onont adressé un courrier commun
où nous demandons des véritbles efforts
sur nos infrastructures dans notre
territoire qui souffr d'un retard
important avec une démographie en forte
hausse la plus importante de la
République quels sont les
investissements monsieur le ministre
dans ce domaine que votre gouvernement
prévoit pour sortir de cette crise de
l'eau structurelle avec les échéances et
les moyens
financiers pouvez-vous rassurer les
collectivités monsieur le ministre qui
s'inquièteent de cette rumeur
qui évoque une reprise en main de l'état
de leurs compétences dans le domaine de
l'eau pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de la transition écologique
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Omar Oli je voudrais d'abord
excuser le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des autres mères ministre des autres
mères qui sont là ni l'un ni l'autre
vous savez que le premier géralde
haranin se rendra le 1er novembre à
Mayotte et que Philippe Vigier y était
le 27 septembre je veux associer dans ma
réponse les ministres de la Santé
Aurélien Rousso etè FM lebudau très
engagés également comment on en est là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment on est là
trois facteurs un déficit
pluviométrique qui auquel nous devons
nous habituer il est la conséquence d'un
dérèglement climatique et qui s'accentue
deuxièmement un afflux de population
vous avez utilisé des mots qui sont en
de ça de la réalité
à aucun moment les infrastructures d'eau
potable de Mayotte n'ont été fait en
imaginant que la proportion de personnes
en situation existant qui n'ont pas été
conduit avec la vitesse et la célérité
qu'il aurait fallu qu'est-ce qu'on fait
la crise la pérennité la crise l'urgence
et la pérenité la crise c'est maintenant
c'est la cellule interministérielle de
crise pilotée par la première ministre
c'est les distributions de bouteilles je
n'insiste pas l'urgence c'est avant
l'été prochain dans des quantités de
travaux que nous lançons déjà et la
pérennité c'est un plan de 2024 2027 400
millions d'euros usine des DESS
allements forage possible retenu cinaire
réutilisation d' usé tous les moyens
tant l'ampleur est importante avec des
taux de fuite qui osilent entre 20 et 35
% sur une partie des réseaux voilà pour
les moyens quelle gouvernance monsieur
le sénateur la compétence elle est
dédiée aux collectivités territoriales
la vérité oblige à dire qu'au cours de
ces dernières années des choses qui
auraient pu fait ne l'ont pas été il n'y
a donc pas de tabou on na pas décidé
d'une ration rationalisation mais nous
considérons que pour passer la crise que
nous connaissons sans un appui
exceptionnel de l'État on y'y arrivera
pas ce sont les sept agents dédiés par
mon ministère c'est les moyens du
ministère de la santé c'est les moyens
des outres mères et qu'audelà de ce
moment-là il faudra qu'on se demande
quel est le bon niveau de soutien et
d'accompagnement de l'État aux
collectivités territoriales merci pour
votre
[Applaudissements]
engagement la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue
pierre meviel pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République
et merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre de
l'agriculture depuis début septembre les
chtel bvin du Grand Sud-Ouest sont
touchés par une maladie virale forte
contagiosité la MHE maladie hémorragique
épisotique transmise par moucheron du
type
cicoïde les premières études engagées
pour consolider nos données sur la
mortalité de cette maladie fournissent
des chiffres dans fourchette allant de
0,3 à 3 %. nous notons également de
nombreux avortements pour une majorité
des cas la guérison intervient au bout
de quelques jours en traitant avec des
anti-inflammatoires non
stéroïdiens mais très
coûteux dans certains cheptel plus de 50
% des animaux sont atteints les mesures
de confinement mises en place dans un
rayon de 150 km autour des foyers n'ont
fait qu'aggraver les conséquences
économiques de cette crise puisque les
éleveurs se sont vu interdire les March
italien espagnol depuis mioctobre ces
marchés sont réautorisés s certaines
conditions cependant
l'épisoti progresse avec un impact
extrêmement lourd sur les finances de
nos
éleveurs monsieur le ministre nous
aurons offert dans quelques semaines un
problème national quelles sont les
mesures prophylactiques qui pourraient
être mis en place le gouvernement a-t-il
prévu des mesures financières
compensatoires afin d'aider les acteurs
de cette filière déjà rudement
impacté pour vous répondre la parole est
au ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc F
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur médiel d'abord pour vous
remercier de poser cette question
puisque comme vous l'avez indiqué nos
éleveurs sont confrontés pour la
première fois à ce virus mche depuis son
apparition à véré le 19 septembre il y
avait trois cas Pyréné Atlantique et
haute pyrénée cette situation de crise
s'aggrave puisque nous sommes passés de
39 foyers le 29 septembre censé à 1200
près de 1200 au mois d'octobre le 20
octobre pour être très précis je vais
d'abord adosser un message de solidarité
aux agriculteurs au aux éleveurs de ces
départements je pense en particulier au
Pyrénées Atlantique et auut Pyrénées qui
sont particulièrement touchés vous dire
que la première priorité qui a été la
ntre c'est d'agir immédiatement sur les
marchés de rentrer en discussion avec
les pays principaux en terme
d'exportation je pense à l'Italie et à
l'Espagne et je vrais remercier mes
collègue italien et espagnol
publiquement puisque en moins de 15
jours ça fait moins d'un mois un peu
plus d'un mois que cet épisode est
arrivé en moins de 15 jours nous avons
pu débloquer la situation via un certain
nombre de mesures sanitaires de
précaution que vous avez évoqué que je
ne réévoque pas qui sont le confinement
autour de 150 km qui ont permis de
crédibiliser la démarche sanitaire de la
France autour de cette maladie
épisotique deuxème élément sur lequel je
veux travailler effectivement au-delà de
ces éléments essentiels qui permettent
de débloquer 95 % de l'export nous avons
devons travailler sur d'autres pays vous
le savez et on continue le travail de
diplomatie sanitaire le deuxè sujet
c'est les conséquences économiques qu'on
voit apparaître au fur et à mesure elles
sont liées au frais V ire au pertes lié
à la morbidité ou à des déficits de
production il nous faut encore évaluer
avec précision ces pertes pour pouvoir
regarder les dispositifs que nous
pourrions mobiliser j'ajoute que depuis
la mise en place l'apparition de cette
maladie on a 40 fermes test qui nous
permettent de suivre au quotidien avec
une un comité de suivi un comité de
crise toutes les semaines qui permet de
suivre les les risques et les impacts
sur les exploitations et donc on attend
un certain nombre de résultats dans les
jours ou les semaines qui viennent pour
regarder et construire avec les
professionnels les dispositifs dont ils
auront besoin pour leur permettre de
passer la crise au-delà de ça cet
épisode il vient montrer quoi que nous
avons besoin de repenser aussi le
financement du sanitaire en France
pourquoi parce qu'on va voir apparaître
de plus en plus MH c'est le un effet du
dérèglement climatique c'était au sud et
sa mon au nord et donc on a besoin de
repenser notre système sanitaire et son
financement et ça c'est un travail de
moyen et long terme je vous remercie
merci Monsieur
béeviel monsieur le ministre je remercie
bon de de prendre en compte cette
situation qui est quand même urgente
bien sûr il est il est trop tôt euh pour
tirer des bilans et sur les conséquences
financières mais ça évolue très
rapidement la crise ukrainienne nous a
quand même rappelé douloureusement notre
nos besoins de souveraineté énergétique
mais surtout alimentaire en ce qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui cette filière
bovine était là sujette de nombreuses
attaques euh trop longtemps les cheptel
diminuent les éleveurs souffrent et
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour ce
fleuron quand même de notre agriculture
donc je compte sur vous sur le
gouvernement pour pour aider cette
filière donc aidons nos éleveurs s'il
vous plaît merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
grvall pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen monsieur
le Président mesames messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues c'est une grande joie c'est un
nouveau départ alors j'aurais pu
m'exprimer comme cela monsieur le
Président pour ma première prise de
parole dans cet hémicycle mais ce n'est
pas moi qui parle c'est Véronique
Véronique 50 ans qui s'exprime ainsi
quand elle signe son contrat à durée
indéterminée
grâce au projet territoire zéro chôur de
longue durée au sein de l'entreprise à
but d'emploi à plombchâteau en Loire
Atlantique comme Véronique plus de 3600
personnes éloignées durablement de
l'emploi ont pu retrouver toute leur
place dans la société mais surtout leur
fierté et leur
dignité cette expérience repose sur
trois principes fondamentaux que le
président Louis Gallois rappelle
inlassablement personne n'est
inemployable ce n'est pas le travail qui
manque
ce n'est pas non plus l'argent qui
manque lancé en 2016 sur 10 sites
territoire zéro chômeurs longue durée
est une véritable réussite depuis la loi
du 14 décembre 2020 48 nouveaux
territoires ont été habilités 98 autres
se sont portés candidats l'Italie et la
Belgique s'en sont inspirés le Comité
européen des régions souhaite lesimer
dans les pays de l'Union européenne or
cette expérience est mise à mal par des
choix budgétaires incompréhens cible en
effet depuis le 1er octobre la
contribution au développement de
l'emploi est passée de 102 % du SMIC à
95 % de plus le budget prévu en 2024
pour territoire zéro chômeurs de longue
durée est largement insuffisant malgré
malgré monsieur le ministre une
augmentation apparente il manque 20
millions d'euros pour courouvrir la
baisse de la contribution au
développement de l'emploi et accompagner
les projets déjà engagés dans ce
contexte pouvez-vous me dire monsieur le
ministre sont les mesures envisagées
pour permettre le bon développement de
ce projet exemplaire et faire en sorte
que les 3600 salariés de cette nouvelle
entreprise ne soit pas condamné à
revenir à la case
départ pour vous répondre la parole et
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion Monsieur Olivier Lop
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur grevallé je sais l'engagement
qui est le votre et qui até le votre
comme élu local pour la promotion des
des expérience territoire zé chemur de
longue durée et le développement des des
entreprises à but d'emploi aujourd'hui
vous l'avez dit nous sommes dans le
cadre d'une expérimentation
expérimentation qui s'appuie sur deux
lois une première loi qui avait autorisé
la création de 10 territoires et une
seconde loi qui a permis de passer à 60
territoires à l'heure où nous parlons il
y a 58 territoires qui ont été agréés et
j'ai systématiquement comme ma
prédécesseur d'ailleurs agréer les
territoires proposés par le Conseil
Scientifique présidé par Monsieur lu
Galois aujourd'hui nous avons 2200 ETP
pour un budget de l'État de 44 millions
d'euros en 2023 cela représente un
engagement de l'État à hauteur de 20000
€ par emploi et je pense que nous devons
avoir le temps d'évaluation ce que nous
avons annoncé et nous devons travailler
sur des perspectives qui soi des
perspectives plus tenables et plus
régulé je m'explique en un mot le budget
de l'État n'est malheureusement
d'ailleurs pas un budget élastique et
nous avons besoin de de moyens pour à la
fois financer ses aides et ses emplois
mais aussi savoir quelle est la
trajectoire de ses emplois faire en
sorte que nous puissions le prévoir tout
simplement pour pouvoir le budgetter
nous sommes sur un financement de 20000
€ par an pour l'État auquel s'ajoute les
financements des conseils départementaux
qui sont tenus de financer pardon mais
j'ai entendu salot de pauvre c'est quand
même honteux de parler comme cela alors
qu'on parle d'une expérience qui permet
d'accompagner des gens qui sont éloignés
de l'emploi vous devriez avoir honte
d'utiliser ces termes là il ne suffit
pas de pardon pardon monsieur le
sénateur mais il ne suffit pas sur les
ban de la gauche pour en avoir les
valeurs et vous en êtes la démonstration
pour ce qui concerne la question de
monsieur grevallet nous sommes prêts à
travailler un meilleur pilotage et un
meilleur pilotage pour aller au-delà des
60 expérimentations et le budget pour
2024 prévoit une augmentation du budget
consacré à territoire zé chôur qui va
passer de 44 à 69 millions
d'euros la parole est à notre collègue
Michel Weber pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
les risques sanitaires liés à
l'utilisation du glyphosate mis en
évidence dans plusieurs études
scientifiques indépendantes ont amené
l'OMS à qualifier cette substance de
cancérogène probable dès 2015 dans son
avis très controversé l'fsa cherche
maladroitement dans relativiser les
risques suite à cet avis la Commission
européenne a proposé aux États-membres
de renouveler son autor tion pour une
durée de 10 ans alors même que les
dangers du glyphosate ne sont plus à
démontrer d'ailleurs nos concitoyens ne
s'y sont pas trompés 2 tiers des
Français rejettent son utilisation en
2017 la France a voté pour la première
fois contre la réautorisation de cet
herbicide dans l'Union européenne pour
une durée de 5 ans la voie de la France
n'a cependant pas suffit pour obtenir
l'interdiction européenne le président
de la République s'était alors engagé à
sortir la France du glyphosate au plus
tard dans 3 ans engagement qu'il a
lui-même enterré dès le fameux grand
débat en 2019 les autorités publiques
ont mis en place un plan d'action de
sortie de cette substance dont
l'efficacité s'est avérée
malheureusement très relative voilà
quelques jours la France par manque de
courage décide de s'abstenir lors du
vote de la proposition de la Commission
européenne sur le renouvellement de la
licence d'utilisation du glyphosate pour
10 ans dans l'Union il ne manquait alors
que deux voies pour obtenir son
interdiction et dans quelques jours un
nouveau scrutin devra définir la
position européenne nous savons qu'en
l'absence de majorité la Commission
prendra la main sur la décision nous
devinons l'issue probable si tel est le
cas monsieur le ministre c'est une
question de santé publique quand
comptez-vous prendre vos responsabilités
et sortir du double discours finalement
quelle est la position de la France
depuis 2015 quel moyens avveit-vous mis
en œuvre pour accompagner le monde
agricole afin de trouver les moyens de
substitution merci pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire
monsieur Marc
fen monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Weber merci de votre question
ça me permettra de faire le point sur
cette question effectivement du
glyphosate qui est parfois une question
un peu polémique et un peu caricaturé
alors je vais vous dire quelle est la
position de la France la position de la
France si c'est polémique et caricaturé
je tiens à le redire je vais vous dire
quelle est la position de la France la
position de la France sur les produits
phytosanitaires c'est d'essayer de tenir
une trajectoire de réduction et cette
trajectoire de réduction pour la
première fois dans le quincen précédent
nous avons commencé à l'amorcer sur le
glyphosate en particulier je rappelle
que sur la période je depuis 2017 nous
avons réduit les usages du glyphosate de
près de 27 % il y a aucun gouvernement
qui a été capable de le faire aucun
aucun ni compris ceux que vous soutenez
ni ceux dans le monde don dont vous
faites référence sur le glyphosate nous
sommes le seul pays avoir réussi à
réduire les usages et donc la position
de la France qui s'est exprimée dans le
débat communautaire je rappelle que
c'est une décision communautaire à
l'échelle de la commission la décision
ça a été de faire en sorte que partout o
on peut trouver des alternatives il n'y
a plus d'utilisation du glyphosate
possible il y a des situations où il n'y
a pas d'alternative possible par exemple
dans l'agriculture de conservation des
sols alors on peut essayer de dire en
permanence il y a qu'à faucon on peut
dire en permanence des alternatives il y
en a mais parfois il faut reconnaître
qu'il y en a pas qu'il a besoin de
recherche et donc nous sommes sur la
trajectoire de la réduction et par
ailleurs s'il n'y a pas de solution il
n'y a pas d'interdiction c'est la ligne
à laquelle nous nous sommes fixés et
c'est la ligne à laquelle nous nous
tiendrons je reviens de je reviens de la
somme je reviens de la somme il y a des
gens en tribune qui sont venus expliquer
qu'il y avait des solutions pour
l'alternative au néonicotinoïdees la
vérité c'est que nous ne les avons
toujours pas on maintient la position
française sur l'interdiction c'est pas
ça le sujet mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que vous n'y pensez parlez-en
à Line Rae parlez-en à Line Rae et donc
on a besoin de travailler sur les
solutions c'est les le sens des moyens
qu'on met sur la recherche sur
l'innovation pour qu'on puisse au fur et
à mesure réduire en tout cas la France
est le seul pays au monde à tenir une
position de réduction sur les
glyphosates et c'est ça qu'on continuera
à
défendreci quelques secondes Jes va ver
quelques
secondes monsieur le ministre je crois
surtout que vous n'êtes pas au
rendez-vous de l'histoire du courage
s'il vous
[Applaudissements]
plaît la parole est à notre collègue
Éric boet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologist kanaki
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues 1000
milliards de dollars ce n'est pas une
exclamation du capitaine adoc ce sont
950 milliards d'euros une somme
vertigineneuse qui correspond au PIB
cumulés du danemarque et de la Belgique
ou encore à trois fois les recettes du
budget de notre pays cette somme
correspond au profit que les grandes
entreprises de la planète ont transféré
vers les paradis fiscaux sur la seule
année 2022 c'est le bilan établi par
l'Observatoire européen de la fiscalité
rendu public cette semaine en lundi
matin nous y apprenons par ailleurs que
les milliards d'air du monde ont un taux
effectif d'imposition compris entre 0 et
0,5 %. à force de baisser constamment
l'impôt sur les sociétés et sur les
grands patrimoines les gouvernements
dont le vôtre rognent eux-mêmes leur
propres recettes l'argument libéral qui
pointe qu'il y a évasion fiscale car les
impôts sont trop élevés ne résistent pas
à l'examen de la ité malgré la pèse
constante des prélèvements sur les
entreprises la fuite des profits reste
constante et son volume ne cesse
d'augmenter pire encore elle a lieu au
cœur de l'Union européenne comme dans
des pays comme l'Irlande ou des Pays-Bas
madame la ministre n'est-il pas temps
pour votre gouvernement de mettre un
terme décisif à cette concurrence
fiscale dévastatrice et d'ouvrir enfin
le chantier de l'harmonisation fiscale
au sein de l'Union
européenne pour vous répondre la parole
la ministre déléguée en charge des
petites et moyennes entreprises vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur Boquet
vous m'interrogez sur l'action du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
la fraude et je me permets de porter à
votre connaissance les éléments transmis
par le ministre des comptes publes
Monsieur Thomas kaznav qui est retenu en
ce moment même à l'Assemblée nationale
et son excuse le gouvernement a présenté
au printemps dernier sur un sujet que
vous connaissez bien le sénateur boet un
plan de lutte contre toutes les fraudes
des aux finances publiques vous l'avez
dit avec force lutter contre la fraude
c'est d'abord s'assurer que chacun
évidemment s'acquite de sa contribution
mais c'est aussi un enjeu de cohésion
sociale et un enjeu de finances publi ce
plan ce sont 1500 emplois
supplémentaires consacrés directement à
la lutte contre la fraude fiscale au
sein même de la Direction générale des
finances publiques d'ici 2027 ça n'est
pas tout c'est aussi et vous le savez un
nouvel arsenal juridique avec une
vingtaine de dispositifs supplémentaires
qui vont vous être proposés à examen
évidemment tel que le renforcement de la
lutte contre les prix de transfert
abusif par exemple nous avançons les
résultats du contrôle fiscal en atteste
en 2022 ce sont près de 15 milliards
d'euros d'impôts éludés qui ont été mis
en recouvrement un montant en hausse de
plus de 25 % par rapport à 2018 sans
féliciter oui sans satisfaire non le
Conseil d'évaluation des fraudes s'est
réuni pour la première fois le 10
octobre dernier sous la présidente du
ministre casenav ce conseil réunit comme
vous vous le savez une trentaine de
membres des directeurs d'administration
des experts internationaux mais aussi
des parlementaires à cette occasion un
programme de travail a été arrêté
l'objectif c'est de produire un rapport
d'ici l'été prochain les représentants
parlementaires ont été désignés par les
présidents des commissions des finances
mais aussi des affaires sociales de
chaque chambre des propositions
complémentaires sont envisagées comme la
création d'un cadastre financier mondial
ou des travaux pour une imposition
minimale des particuliers les plus
fortunés à l'échelle interntional avec
ces nouveaux outils nous allons être en
mesure d'atteindre un objectif que nous
partageons être intraitable contre les
encornifleurs qui pratiquent la fraude
sociale je vous remercie
oui madame la ministre des paroles aux
actes je crains madame la ministre que
notre pays ne soit une partie du
problème du fait des choix faits par
votre majorité en faisant adopter
dernièrement à l'Assemblée nationale un
amendement qui exonère d'impôt société
de cotisation foncière et sur la valeur
ajouter les entreprises afin d'attirer
en France les fédérations sportives
internationales votre majorité alimente
cette course folle au moins 10 ans
fiscal si dommageable pour nos finances
publiques et les grands défis que notre
société a
relevé parole est à notre collègue
Michel bonus pour le groupe les
République Monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre des Sports madame la
ministre dans cette période très
troublée l'équipe de France de Ruby nous
a donné de la joie nous a rendu fier
parce qu'elle avait du cœur et qu'elle
en envie de bien faire sur le terrain et
en dehors le sport n pas son pareil pour
véhiculer les valeurs forte noble celle
de l'effort du travail du respect du
collectif et de la solidarité le sport
n'a pas son paré pour cadrer les enfants
des adolescents et en faire des adultes
responsables des citoyens entachés aux
valeurs de la République nous ne
remercions jamais assez le travail des
éducateurs et des bénévoles et je me
réjouis que le Président de la
République a annoncé que le sport serait
grande cause nationale pour 2024 le
sport comme facteur d'émancipation et de
liberté j'en suis intimement convaincu
enfit en théorie parce que le sport à
l'image de notre société est attaqué
pire il est un des milieux privilégiés
pour déstabiliser notre République et
promouvoir le séparatisme prière dans
les vestière por du voile sur le terrain
refus de la mixité discours prosélite
antirépublicain des attaques séparati se
multiplie insidieusement mais de plus en
plus souvent ouvertement au sein de nos
structures Sportiv des travaux du Sénat
de l'Assemblée nationale des chercheurs
des sociologues et des éducateurs tous
établissent ce même constat àablant le
sport la République perd du terrain dans
le sport les islamistes ne s'en cachent
plus d'ailleurs les clubs de sport sont
leur principale source de recrutement et
d'embrigadement il y a quelques semaines
69 club de basket ont conjointement
réclamé le port du voile en compétition
alors interdit un comble
Gabriel Atal ministre de l'éducation
nationale a fait preuve de fermeté n'a
pas tremblé en interdisant laaba dans
nos écoles alors madame la ministre ma
question est simple pour défendre les
malurs de la République il faut être
ferme êtes-vous prête à interdire toute
pratique qui déroge au principe de
laïcité et menace notre
République pour vous
[Applaudissements]
répondre la parole est à la ministre des
sport des Jeux Olympiques et paralympiqu
madame oua Castera vous avez la parole
madame la ministre monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bonus le sujet du
séparatisme dans le sport il exige de la
fermeté de la lucidité de la vigilance
c'est en ce sens que j'ai fait
diligenter au cours de l'année écoulé
près de 3500 contrôles de clubs sportifs
sur lesquels 27 ont donné lieu au
répérage de signaux faibles de
séparatisme 0,8 %. c'est toujours 0,8 %
de trop et il faut en effet prévenir les
risques là où ils se trouvent d'où le
plan d'action que j'ai mis en œuvre de
manière résolue 117 référents prévention
de la radicalisation mis en place dans
les services déconcentrés du ministère
des Sports des références citoyenneté
mobilisé dans les fédérations un
programme de contrôle 6000 contrôle
programmé pour cette année dans les
clubs sportifs et un processus de
conventionnement lancé entre 11
fédérations et le comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquence et de la radicalisation avec
le tout des moyens supplémentaires 20
effectifs en 203 36 en 2024 sur ces
sujets s'agissant du port du voile j'ai
salué la décision du Conseil d'État de
valider les statuts de la fédération
française de foot indiquant que le port
du voile pouvait être interdit en
compétition pendant le temps et le lieu
des matchs j'ai conforté ce régime dans
la Fédération Française de Basket et
j'ai fait connaître à chacune des
fédérations que dans l'exercice autonome
de leur pouvoir réglementaire elles
avaient la faculté d'ajuster leur statut
pour coller à ces mêmes disposition nous
les accompagnons en ce sens en leur
donnant toutes les clés y compris
juridiques sur ces sujets-là je le redit
très fermement ma main ne tremblera
jamais pour faire utiliser les moyens
que notre gouvernement a fait inscrire
dans la loi le respect du le contrôle du
respect du contrat d'engagement
républicain retirer des subventions
suspendre des agréments ou fermer si
nécessaire des établissements le sport
est un bien précieux il doit être
préservé de ces tentations mais ég
des propos inutilement polémi ou
inutilement anxiogène
lucidité vigilance et la plus grande des
fermetés merci Monsieur bonus vous avez
quelques
secondes quelques secondes j'ai quelques
secondes merci Mad ministre vous savez
rendre les fédérations autonomes ce
sujet c'est très dangereux ils ont
besoin de VOUS ils ont besoin d'être aid
on peut pas leur donner les clés et dire
vous allez décider c'est très dangereux
voilà j'ai pas de réponse parce que
c'est ça ça m'a
perturbé
la parole est à notre collègue Marion
Canales pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
merci mes chers collègues ma question
concerne expérimentation territoire zéro
chômeur de longue durée et j'associe ma
collègue Karine Daniel aucun répis aucun
repli aucun répi face à la crise sociale
et au chômage aucun repli pour cette
expérimentation qui a déjà permis à 3600
personnes de sortir de la privation
d'emploi voté à deux reprises à deux
reprises au Parlement à l'unanimité
cette expérimentation a été saluée par
madame la ministre du Travail en 2020
comme une solution d'insertion sur
mesure cononstruite avec la société
civile son utilité sociale et
démocratique et cité en exemple par la
Commission européenne l'Italie et la
Belgique dupliquent le modèle à l'été
première saison vous avez pourtant
choisi de baisser la contribution de
l'État au financement des emplois créés
de près de 1500 € par an par emploi euh
par emploi à l'automne 2e saison le
budget prévisionnel certes dynamique
n'est pas à la hauteur de l'enjeu il est
insuffisant il ne permettra pas la
montée en puissance pourtant acté gala
les perspectives d'embauche dans les
territoires habilités et ceux qui sont
prêts fragiliser le modèle c'est
précipiter l'échec pourtant partout les
résultats positifs sont visibles et
dépassent le cadre largement de la
personne concernée en 7 ans à tiers dans
le puit d'Ô le taux de réussite au
brevets des collèges a grimpé de 12 de
12 % on ne peut pas feindre d'ignorer
que territoire zéro chômeur a contribué
en partie à cette dynamique vertueuse
les territoires les collectivités sont
au rendez-vous le Parlement à
l'unanimité a au rendez-vous les acteurs
employeurs privés publics de l'économie
sociale et solidaire sont au rendez-vous
les effets positifs sont au rendez-vous
cela un coût mais cela n'a pas de prix
de l'argent il y en a Monsieur le
Ministre de l'argent il en faut pour
tenir les engagements pris 20 millions
d'euros quel moyen allez-vous mobiliser
durablement pour la France qui essaie
qui qui innove et qui fait la
démonstration de sa
réussite pour
répondre la parole est à ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice Canales
permettez-moi de vous répondre ça n'est
pas la coutume mais avec des questions
pour vous faire partager aussi la même
difficulté vous dites ça n'est pas
suffisant de financer un emploi à 95 %.
95 % de prise en charge au niveau du
SMIC c'est le plus haut taux de
financement des emplois aidés que l'on
connaît dans notre pays toutes les
structures d'insertion par l'activité
économique aimeraiit pouvoir bénéficier
de la même chose la deuxième chose vous
nous dites il faut accompagner tous les
développements et toutes les
perspectives je pose une autre question
à la réflexion collective les
départements par la loi la deuxème loi
que tout le monde a voté à l'unanimité
doivent apporter 15 % du budget global
des expérimentations est-ce que tous les
départements sont d'accord pour que les
15 % qu'ils doivent apporter
représentent des sommes dont ils n'ont
pas la maîtrise la réponse est non
nombre nombre des présidents de
département me l'ont dit vous me dites
le budget que vous prévoyez pour
l'expérimentation est dynamique mais pas
suffisant il passe de 44 à 69 millions
d'euros c'est une une augmentation de 53
%. là aussi toutes les structure
d'insertion par l'activité économique
aimerait pouvoir bénéficier de la même
chose j'ai eu et mon plus
particulièrement mon cabinet eu de
nombreux échanges tout au long du mois
d'octobre avec le président lu Galois
qui s'occupe du conseil scientifique et
qui propose la labellisation du
gouvernement de nouveaux territoires
vendredi soir je tiens le message à
votre disposition mon directeur de
cabinet a proposé à Monsieur Gallois que
au cours de l'année 202 4 en fonction de
leurs besoins nous puissions ajouter 10
millions supplémentaires à une condition
que nous puissions anticiper sur les
créations d'emplois et avoir une
projection qui nous permett de prévoir
tout simplement de prévoir la
mobilisation de l'argent public il a
essuillé un refus c'est dommage mais
nous allons continuer à discuter pour
voir comment accompagner cette
expérimentation mais le faire dans un
cadre qui est le cadre budgétaire deétat
je l'ai dit le budget d'État ça n'est
pas élastique ça n'est pas un libre
service dans lequel on peut piocher au
gré d'un développement que l'État ne
pourrait pas maîtriser nous sommes sur
un niveau d'intervention qui n' jamais
existé l'évaluation qui est en cours va
aussi le
montrer Madame
C monsieur le ministre on passe de 102 %
de cofinancement des emplois à 95 on ne
change pas les règles en cours par
ailleurs pour abonder les le les les
finances publiques des pistes il y en a
rétablissement de l'ISF taxation des
super profits le le collègue tout à
l'heure a fait quelques propositions de
l'argent il y en a on peut en trouver de
l'argent il en faut pour le territoire
zé chômeur et les personnes
bénéficiaires
parole est à notre collègue Jean-Marc
Boyer pour le groupe les
républicains ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur la
moitié des sénateurs de cette assemblée
sortent d'une campagne électorale et
leur constat est très clair les maires
de nos communes rurales ont besoin de
notre soutien pour se développer qui
mieux que les élus pour connaître leur
territoire et leurs besoins qui mieux
que les élus pour les soutenir or vous
avez supprimé la dotation d'action
parlementaire d réserve parlementaire en
septembre 2017 pour soi-disant rétablir
la confiance dans la vie politique
pourquoi avoir recentralisé le soutien
aux communes rurales dans les mains de
l'État car nous le savons tous les
parlementaires au sein de la commission
DTR ne disposent que d'un avis
consultatif pourtant ce sont eux qui
connaissent les territoires cette
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
a même été vécu comme un abandon avec la
promesse de fonds de compensation qui
n'ont jamais vu le jour alors Monsieur
le Ministre afin de corriger cette
erreur et afin de soutenir au plus près
nos communes rurales allez-vous rétablir
la réserve
parlementaire pour vous répondre la
parole est à la ministre déléguée en
charge des collectivités territoriales
madame Dominique
fort merci monsieur le Président je vous
demande de bien vouloir excuser
géralanin ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le sénateur Jean-Marc Boyet
alors la
DR est un outil essentiel d'aménagement
et vous le savez de nos
territoires ruraux particulièrement elle
a doublé elle a doublé ces 10 dernières
années elle a soutenu
22 elle a doublé elle a soutenu 22000
projets dans toute la France dans 15000
communes 800 EPCI 550 syndicat c'est 1
milliard qui a été mis sur la table pour
4 milliards d'investissements c'est
cette effet de levier que je tenais à
souligner ensuite nous sommes
particulièrement exigeants vis-à-vis des
préfets sur la façon dont la DETR est
utilisée elle doit aller partout elle va
partout y compris dans la ruralité la
plus profonde vous le savez les préfets
consultent obligatoirement la Commission
des de chaque département avant de faire
leur répartition cette gouvernance est
extrêmement importante elle permet de
vérifier qu'on ne distribue pas la DR
sur la base d'un travail administratif
réalisé en chambre mais dans un vrai
dialogue avec les élus nous y sommes
extrêmement attachés ces commissions
réunissent déjà de nombreux acteurs nous
ne sommes nous ne sommes donc pas
favorables à ce qu'on en augmente le
nombre on ne décide pas mieux parce
qu'on est plus nombreux autour de la
table par contre nous avons une exigence
sur l'information de tous les
parlementaires même ceux qui ne siègent
pas dans cette commission le préfet doit
tous les appeler pour vérifier que la
répartition est partagée c'est le cas
dans de nombreux départements j'en suis
à 105 visites de département 40 és de
maire personne ne me parle d'un problème
sur la façon dont la DETR est
répartie par ailleurs ma collègue la
secrétaire d'État pr a engagé un travail
sur la gouvernance du fond de
développement de la vie associative et
je suis certaine que nous pouvons y
travailler tous ensemble merci à tous
monsieur
Boyer s'il vous plaît c'est moi qui
réparti la parole si ça n'est pas la
DETR monsieur Boyer je vous remercie
madame la ministre je vous avais
interrogé sur la réserve
parlementaire alors il est temps
effectivement de redonner des moyens et
soutenir le développement de nos
territoires ruraux tels que le Sénat a
déjà pu le demander avec l'adoption d'un
amendement en octobre 2020 que j'avais
présenté et fait adopter afin de
rétablir la réserve parlementaire suivi
d'une proposition de loi en juillet 2022
que signé par plus d'une centaine de
sénateurs afin d'instituer une dotation
parlementaire au sein de la de la DTR
les démarches parlementaires récentes
d'ailleurs confirment ces initiatives et
mettent au grand jour cette suppression
injuste pour nos territoires notre
démocratie a soif de de décentralisation
notre démocratie demande de renforcer le
lien entre le local et le National
renforcer le lien entre le maire et le
parlementaire et redonner du pouvoir de
décision aux élus nationaux dans un
esprit de concertation collégial en
transparence et en confiance les maires
des territoires ruraux le sollicitent et
il le méritent
bien la parole est
au président Jean-François longjau pour
le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie monsieur le ministre nous
sommes en train de troquer notre
ancienne dépendance au pétrole contre
une nouvelle dépendance au métau RAR
chinois le piège de cette nouvelle
dépendance est en train de se refermer
puisque vendredi dernier le ministère du
Commerce chinois a annoncé qu'à part à
partir du 1er décembre il réclamera un
permis d'exportation pour certains
produits en graphite la Chine est le
premier producteur de graphite du monde
assurant près de 70 % de la production
mondiale plus problématique encore
c'estelle qui raffine 90 % de la
production planétaire de graphite
aujourd'hui sans la Chine pas de
graphite sans graphite pas de batterie
car c'est en graphit que sont faites
leur électrodes et sans batterie bien
entendu pas de transition énergétique
début août la Chine avait restreint
l'exportation de Gallum et de germanium
indispensable au circuit intégré au
panneau voltaïque ou à la fibre optique
nous ne découvrons pas notre dépendance
au métorir chinois l'Union européenne
établit depuis 2011 une liste de
matières premières critiqu en 2016 j'ai
moi-même réalisé avec Marie-Christine
Blandin un rapport pointant la nécessité
de de recycler les métaux des téléphones
portables en 2022 monsieur Varin a remis
au président de la République un rapport
sur la sécurisation de l'apprisionnement
matièrees premièr en mars dernier la
Commission européenne a proposé deux
textes pour y faire face et en mai la
France a lancé un fond d'investissement
mais tout ceci est encore embrionnaire
et c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir
monsieur le ministre travaillez-vous à
un plan d'urgence pour faire face à une
rupture d'approvisionnement en métau je
vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie du commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le Président Longo
oui vous avez parfaitement raison la
Chine a annoncé le 20 octobre dernier
des mesures de contrôle à l'exportation
du graphite qui est une matière première
indispensable pour la fabrication de
beaucoup de nos batteries et notamment
pour la transition énergétique vers le
véhicule électrique cela fait suite à
des décisions déjà rendues en juillet
sur d'autres matières premières comme le
Gallum ou le
germanium nous étudions aujourd'hui
l'impact de cette situation avec à la
fois la Délégation interministérielle
aux approvisionnements en minerés en
métocritique et l'Observatoire français
des ressources
minérales comment répondre aujourd'hui
parce que c'est ça la véritable question
d'abord
en se coordonnant avec l'ensemble des
pays de l'Union européenne mais
également nos alliés c'est une question
qui sera posée notamment dans le cadre
du G7 commerce à Osaka ce weekend auquel
je me rends derrière nous mettons en
place une véritable diplomatie des
matières premières nous souhaitons
développer pour dérisquer les risques
sur la Chine nous souhaitons devvelopper
une stratégie de diversification des
approvisionnements d'où l'intérêt
également des accords commerciaux et des
accords internationaux que nous avons
avec d'autres pays ou d'autres régions
du monde pour sécuriser justement les
approvisionnements vers l'Europe enfin
il faut pouvoir et vous l'avait très
justement dit traiter raffiner ces
matières directement sur le sol européen
c'est aussi la stratégie industrielle à
laquelle travaille le gouvernement et
nous n'hésiterons pas également à
soutenir un certain nombre de projets
financièrement dans le cadre des plans
qui sont prévus à cet effet je vous
remercie monsieur le Président
longjau la parole est à notre collègue
Béatrice goselin pour le le groupe les
républicains monsieur le ministre ma
question porte sur le soutien à la
filière pêche et j'associe ma collègue
Vivette Lopez sénatrice du gare à mes
propos les pêcheurs vivent une crise
sans précédent aux conséquen du brexit
s'ajoute une envolée des coûts du
carburant certes la filière a bénéficier
de 100 millions d'euros issu de la
réserve d'ajustement du brexit sur les
736 millions alloués à la France par
l'Union européenne mais le 1er mars 2023
notre pays a demandé le transfert de 504
millions d'euros non dépensés pour
financer le programme REPER
euu même si toute l'enveloppe n'était
pas destinée à la filière il aurait
peut-être éé pertinent d'augmenter les
fonds dédiés à la pêche car de nombreux
défis sont à relever pérenniser les
carburant autrement que par des mesures
d'urgence en reconduisant le régime
spécifique Ukraine en 2024 avec un
plafond de 300000 € d'aide augmenter les
plafonds des aides de minimi
actuellement 30000 € d'aides par
entreprise et pour 3 ans ou prévoir au
moins un dispositif de minimi par navire
et non plus par entreprise accompagner
et ça sera très important la transition
énergétique des
nav
pardon améliorer les services publics
dans les ports le port de Grandville
attend depuis 3 ans un service d'ruc
d'inspection vétérinaire et
phytosanitaire dit civep dont l'absence
a des conséquences économiques
importantes puisqu'il oblige les navires
à faire un détour par saint-malot la
pêche est une richesse pour notre
économie elle fait vivre nos littoraux
au travers d'emplois non délocalisables
et participe à la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays la fili a
vraiment besoin d'une ambition à court
moyen et long terme alors j'ai deux
questions monsieur le ministre pourquoi
avoir laissé filer des crédits européens
qui aent ét si utile à la filière et
quels sont les engagements du
gouvernement pour assurer pour assurer
notre pêcheur sur avenir
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
au secrétaire d'État chargé de la mer
monsieur HERV Berville monsieur le
ministre avez la parole merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice goselin
alors
vous l'avez évoqué la France n'a pas
laissé filer 504 millions d'euros et il
n'y a pas de cagnotte magique cachée
qu'on aurait pas utilisé la réalité
c'est que la réserve d'ajustement brexit
a été bien utilisée a été utilisée pour
ce pourquoi elle avait été conçue
c'est-à-dire de faire face aux
conséquences directes du brexit que ce
soit social environnementale ou
économique et en ce qui concerne par
exemple le ministère de la mer et les
enjeux de pêche plus de 100 millions
d'euros ont été utilisés et d'ailleurs
la Cour des comptes l'a reconnu
elle-même c'est un des ministères qui
l'a mieux utilisé notamment pour le plan
d'accompagnement individuel des navires
qui ne peuvent pas accéder aux EAU
britanniques ou encore pour accompagner
laav de la filière notamment les
marilleeurs et donc ce que nous avons
fait c'est d'utiliser les autres canaux
qui étaient disponible pour accompagner
nos pêcheurs face à l'urgence et donc
vous voyez le fait de ne pas avoir de
réserve d'ajustement brexit nous a pas
empêché d'accompagner les pêcheurs nous
l'avons fait avec plus de 75 millions
d'euros pour l'aide carburant avec un
renouvellement de cette D qui a ét été
multiplié par 10 et vous l'avez dit mais
c'était une erreur vous avez dit que
c'était 30000 non nous avons fait passer
le le seuil de 3000 à 330000 € et ça
c'est grâce à l'action de la France et
ensuite vous l'avez évoqué au-delà de la
question de l'urgence de l' carburant ce
qu'il nous faut c'est de réduire notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai annoncé en
septembre de cette année et bien un plan
de transition énergétique de la flotte
de 450 millions d'euros issu de L TEX
éolienne en mer pour justement réduire
cette dépendance auénergie fossile et
faire en sorte que nous tenions les deux
bouts de la chaîne souveraineté
énergétique et souverineté alimentaire
donc vous le voyez madame la sénatrice
le gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour faire face aux urgences et
pleinement mobilisé pour donner les
moyens aux pêcheurs de continuer à
sortir en mer et pleinement mobilité
pour faire en sorte que partout sur nos
territoires nous ayons encore des
pêcheurs avec des navire qui consomment
beaucoup moins de carburant je vous
remercie madame gos vous avez quelques
secondes
monsieur le ministre vous savez comme
moi qu'en 2026 il y aura revoyure pour
les contrats de pêche de nos pêcheurs
donc le brexit c'est encore aussi 2026
et ça sera un gros problème pour eux
s'ils n'ont pas d'aide merci
[Musique]
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Corine
narassigen pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la première
ministre le 10 octobre dernier
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe a adopté à une grande majorité
un rapport ainsi que une résolution
pointant de nombreuses violations par la
France de ses obligations relatives à
son adhésion au Conseil de l'Europe
usage abusif du 493 surpopulation
carcérale structurelle problème avec la
doctrine du maintien de l'ORD pendant
les gilets jaunes et pendant les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites questionnement sur
l'indépendance de la justice
concentration des médias qui nuit au
pluralisme le en de plus le 18 octobre
le Conseil d'État s'est opposé à
l'interdiction systématique des
manifestations propalestiniennes en
contradiction avec une consigne du
ministère de l' l'intérieur adressée au
préfet enfin votre gouvernement vient
d'enclencher le 13e 493 sur le PLF 2024
en battant des records de vitesse et le
14e est imminent sur le PLFSS vous
privez les députés de tout débat et de
tout vote madame la Première ministre où
emmenez-vous ainsi notre
démocratie pour vous répondre la parole
est à la secrétaire d'État en charge de
l'Europe vous avez la parole madame la
ministre merci merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Corine Nar
sigin l'adoption nous avons bien Adé
l'adoption du rapport de l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe et
comme vous savez celui-ci est rédigé par
une commission de suivi qui est composée
de parlementaires les travaux sont sans
contexte d'excellentees qualité
néanmoins vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que c'est une assemblée consultative et
dont les rapporteurs choisissent
eux-mêmes le thème de leur rapport il
n'est donc pas totalement impossible
d'envisager que le choix de la
thématique est été guidé par quelques
considérations politiques ni l'avis du
secrétaire général d'ailleurs ni cell
des autres organes décisionnaires ne
sont engagés par ce rapport ceci étant
dit nous étudions évidemment avec
attention les recommandations sur le
côté positif je suis sûr que vous avez
vu qu'il saluaiit les efforts qui ont
été déployés par la France pour
renforcer l'indépendance des autorité
judiciaire sur les données des forces de
l'ordre je suis un peu étonné parce
qu'en fait l'IGPN et l'iggn recense le
nombre de blessés et de tués pendant des
millions des missions de police pardon
et en 2022 il était de 5 % le nombre de
blessés soit 4 cas voilà donc en
conclusion nous allons continuer de
suivre et voir ce que nous pouvons
améliorer et ensuite pardon sur le 493
je vous rappelle qu'il a été approuvé
par la Constitution avec un score de
près de 86 % en 1958 renforcé en 2008 et
qu'il fait partie de nos appareils
constitutionnels et oui c'est comme ça
c'est la Constitution je vous
remercie madame Nara
sigin madame la ministre vous vous
dédoinez bien vite la France a également
été condamnée à de multiples reprises
par la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme pour sa surpopulation carcérale
et sa politique migratoire et votre
gouvernement s'apprête à restreindre les
droits les plus fondamentaux des
personnes migrantes dans le cadre du
projet de loi immigration qui arrive par
ailleurs le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur man a un déclaré ce weekend
qu'il assumait les condamnations de la
CEDH et qu'il était prêt à soutenir les
propositions de la droite LR visant à
s'asseoir sur nos obligations
européennes le tout après avoir attaqué
la Ligue des droits de l'homme il y a
quelques mois vous emmenez la France pas
à pas vers un régime illibéral et vous
le
savez parole est à notre collègue
Laurence müllerbron pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains ma question s'adressait à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur donc
il n'est pas là madame la ministre en
mai dernier le maire de Saint-Brévin
Lespin est victime d'un incendie
criminel et de violence déclenchée par
l'installation d'un centre d'accueil
pour migrants il démissionnait faute
d'avoir été soutenu et protégé par les
services de l'État qui l'auraiit
pourtant alerté en réponse à ces
défaillances inacceptables le
gouvernement a fait son méaculpa et
s'est engagé à travailler avec les élus
pour assurer leur sécurité et prévenir
les tensions hélas prévisibles notamment
dans les projets d'installation
d'hébergement d'urgence or le
gouvernement fait exactement l'inverse
il vient de passer en force le 25
septembre dernier contre l' vie unanime
des élus locaux le décret numéro
2023-894 qui qui impose au maire
l'installation de centes d'hébergement
d'urgence dans leur commune sans leur
demander leur avis et Seris sur le
gâteau sans même avoir l'obligation de
les en informer madame la ministre ne
s'agit-il pas d'hypocrisie
d'État pour répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
citoyenneté de la ville madame Sabrina
agristi roubach merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice müerbron
euh le décret que vous évoquez pérénise
un dispositif qui a été mis en place en
juin 2021 et qui a permis de faciliter
d'accélérer certaines opérations
spécifiques et
temporaires ce décret permet en effet de
dans certaines zones de dispenser de se
dispenser d'autorisation d'urbanisme de
sur l'implantation pour une durée
maximale de 24 mois certaines
constructions temporair et démonable
teles que les résidences universitaires
je vous le rappelle les résidences
sociales les centres d'hébergement
et de réinsertion sociale et les
structures d'hébergement d'urgence sur
ce dernier point ce décret permet par
exemple dans une démarche d'urbanisme
transitoire de faciliter l'implantation
de construction temporaire destinée à
l'hébergement d'urgence sur des fonciers
en attente d'urbanisation notamment nous
avons également élargi son champ
d'application je vous le précise aux
constructions à usage de relogement
temporaire rendu nécessaire par les
opérations réalisées dans le cadre du
npnru ces opérations à tiroir que vous
connaissez probablement qui doivent
rester exceptionnels peuvent s'avérer
incontournables pour la réalisation de
certaines opérations de reconstruction
du patrimoine social de la
réhabilitation lourde ou de démolition
dans le cadre de ces
programmes ces règles ont donc été
établi pour l'ensemble des structures
d'hébergement et non de manière
spécifique pour les structures
accueillants des demandeurs d'asile je
vous le précise la création de l'accueil
de de place d'accueil pardon dans le
dispositif national d'asile obéi à un
national décliné territorialement le
gouvernement apporté la création de
30000 nouvelles places depuis 2017
démontrant notre engagement pour
accueillir de manière digne pour
organiser cet accueil dans les
meilleures conditions les préfets ont
pour instruction claire du ministre de
l'Intérieur d'associer étroitement tous
les élus à la création de nouvelles
places d'accueil pour les centres
d'hébergement je vous
remercie la ministre décision a été
prise de façon autoritaire les
représentants des élus se sont prononcés
à l'unanimité et deux fois par deux fois
contre ce décret qui pérénise pour 2 ans
et peut-être plus une situation qui
était prévue pour durer 3 mois ce décret
dispense de tout contrôle des formalités
d'urbanisme et échappe à l'autorité
locale ni concerté ni consulté et
pourtant placé en première ligne dans
l'organisation du quotidien vous le
savez les derniers mois les projets
d'installation en Bretagne dans la
commune de Bru ou dans le Tarne sur la
commune de Réalmont sont des échecs
parce qu'en milieu rural les services
publics nécessaires à l'accompagnement
l'éducation l'insertion et à la sécurité
sont très insuffisants une nouvelle fois
le gouvernement crée de la division et
avec une violence bien feutrée
déstabilise les équilibres territoriaux
il passe outre la vie des mares qui
deviennent spectateurs d'une politique
dont ils auront pourtant à assumer les
risques les responsabilités à la place
de l'État et surtout les conséquences et
si l'État lui-même n'a pas de respect
pour l'autorité locale votre politique
ne peut conduire qu'au désordrre et à
l'échec la parole est à notre collègue
Damien michalé pour le groupe les
républicains merci merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outres
maires monsieur le ministre j'ai été
comme vous maire de ma commune et comme
tant d'autres élus locaux j'ai été
confronté à l'occupation illégale de
terrain notamment par les gens du voyage
comme tant d'autres élus locaux je me
suis retrouvé désarmé face à ces
individus qui sont en réalité de fin
connaisseur de notre législation et qui
rate manifestement une brillante
carrière de juriste alors dans cette
situation que fait l'élu local il s'en
remet à la justice or force est de
constater que si la saisine du juge
abouti parfois sur l'expulsion des
occupants illégaux cette décision
d'expulsion est rarement assortie d'une
autorisation de recours à la force
publique pour exemple en mai dernier le
tribunal judiciaire de Vienne a décidé
de faire droit à la requête d'une
intercommunalité la capie qui demandait
au juge au juges l'expulsion sans délai
des personnes des animaux et des
caravanes appartenant à des individus
sur la commune de la Verpillère
seulement monsieur le ministre
l'autorité préfectorale ne peut pas
faire procéder alors
évacuation pourquoi parce qu'en réalité
l'ordonnance mentionne bien l'expulsion
mais l'autorisation du recours aux
forces de l'ordre public est rayé d'un
coup de crayon du magistrat monsieur le
ministre face à ces situations qui
mettent à mal le moral de nos élus
locaux leur légitimité et parfois leur
intégrité physique pouvez-vous nous
éclairer sur la doctrine employée par le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour assurer
l'application stricte des décision
d'expulsion pouvez-vous nous prouver que
l'État mettra en place tous les moyens
nécessaires pour garantir aux él que le
recours à la justice en France n'est pas
vain pour vous répondre la parole est à
la ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur michalé
il y a deux sujets 10 join je pensais
que vous faisz faisiez référence à des
rassemblements de gens du voyage et en
fait vous évoquez le sujet structurant
et là pour le coup que je rencontre à
chacun de mes déplacements c'est
effectivement la difficulté quand les
intercommunalités et elles le sont très
souvent sont en conformité avec la loi
n'arrivve pas à faire appliquer
effectivement la loi donc je vais
prendre contact avec vous à l'issue de
cette séance parce que je suis
extrêmement désireuse de voir dans
quelle mesure aujourd'hui on pourrait
peut-être donner les moyens à nos juges
de juger comme nous aujourd'hui
considérons qu'il est nécessaire de le
faire sur le sujet des rassemblements
parce que je pensais que vous faisiez
allusion à celui de
Cessieux sur votre département je
voulais simplement vous dire à quel
point je suis convaincu aussi que les
aires que vous avez sur vos communes et
que nous avons sur nos communes ne sont
pas forcément effectivement adaptés à
des rassemblements donc sur cet autre
sujet qui n'est pas l'objet de votre
question j'ai un certain nombre de j'ai
un certain nombre de réponses et je suis
aussi extrêmement attachée
à travailler avec vous pour faire en
sorte que nos élus locaux puissent
effectivement voir la loi appliquer euh
de façon plus stricte Merci à
VOUS
chal merci merci Madame la Ministre
alors avec plaisir je vous accueillerai
en iser je vois que vous avez bien
affuté votre connaissance sur ce
territoire mais au-delà de l'isè il
s'agit bien d'une problématique
nationale tant pour les regroupements ou
les grands regroupements que pour
puisque là là il s'agissait précisément
d'une non application d'ordonnance du
tribunal judiciaire où on était
précisément sur quelque chose qui met à
mal toutes les décisions que notre
justice française pourrait prendre mais
je vous accueillerai avec grand plaisir
madame la
ministre
bien nous avons terminé avec les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 8 novembre
à 15h je vais suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 16h30 pour la suite de la
proposition de loi visant à améliorer
l'accès aux soins par l'engagement
territorial des professionnels la séance
est
suspendue